[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg
willkommen an diesem Samstagabend
Norbert König ist auch dabei für den
Sport guten Abend und das sind die
Nachrichten Themen von heute
Affäre Aiwanger der Chef der Freien
Wähler lehnt einen Rücktritt weiter ab
ob ihnen Ministerpräsident Söder halten
wird ist bis zur Stunde ungewiss
Botschaft aus der Mongolei in dem Land
zwischen Russland und China ruft Papst
franziskus zufrieden in der Welt auf
und Geldregen am Main für kolomyani
bekommt die Eintracht 95 Millionen nur
wer soll jetzt für Frankfurt stürmen
[Musik]
der Ball liegt jetzt bei Markus Söder
der bayerische Ministerpräsident muss
entscheiden ob er seinen vize-eiwanger
kurz vor der Landtagswahl entlässt der
Chef der Freien Wähler hat in der Affäre
um einen antisemitisches Flugblatt so
das Fragenkatalog beantwortet und sieht
überhaupt keinen Grund für Entlassung
oder Rücktritt die Opposition verlangt
das Fragen und Antworten veröffentlicht
werden Alexander Pool
das Aubinger Herbstfest bei München
eigentlich ein ganz normaler
Wahlkampftermin für Markus Söder doch
heute warten alle auf eine Entscheidung
zum Fall
aiwangert einen schönen Tag sagt's und
lächelt den Fall Aiwanger erstmal weg
dann irgendwo im Getümmel wenigstens
eine kurze Antwort
alles wird sauber geprüft fünf Wochen
vor der Landtagswahl in Bayern Hubert
Aiwanger ist für Söder zu einer
Belastung geworden was nun nachdem
Aiwanger den Fragenkatalog der CSU zu
der antisemitischen Hetzschrift
beantwortet hast bei der CSU Basis sind
die Meinungen zu Aiwanger differenziert
es hat ja jeder blöd macht er jetzt
vielleicht bloß gleich
am Ende ich glaube zwischen jugendzünde
und antisemitischen Äußerungen ist halt
doch ein großer Unterschied ich würde
mit einwanger weitermachen weitermachen
das will Hubert Albaner auf jeden Fall
der bayerische Wirtschaftsminister heute
zu Gast in Hessen spricht im
Zusammenhang mit der flugplatzaffäre von
moderne Hexenjagd auf ihn die Koalition
mit der csu-sonne weitergehen ich weiß
nicht zu welcher Entscheidung der
Ministerpräsident kommt aber ich sehe
nach meinen Antworten überhaupt keinen
Grund für einen Rücktritt oder eine
Entlassung die meisten hier in Hessen
denken genauso im Moment haben wir immer
noch die Unschuldsvermutung hier in
Deutschland bin nicht der Ansicht ohne
Vorverurteilung sollte hier nicht
stattfinden es sollte auf keinen Fall
zurücktreten aber er hätte von Anfang an
viel offener eben reden müssen die
Opposition in Bayern fordert heute
Offenheit von Markus Söder ich verstehe
wenn Markus Söder sich jetzt etwas Zeit
nimmt für eine schwere Entscheidung aber
ich finde dass die Fragen und vor allem
auch die Antworten natürlich
veröffentlicht werden müssen weil so
eine Entscheidung kann jetzt nicht
einfach im Hinterzimmer getroffen werden
wann Süder entscheidet ist nach wie vor
offen
er entlassen oder nicht Stefan leifert
in München warum tun sich Markus Söder
und die CSU so schwer mit dieser
Entscheidung
[Musik]
bei Markus Söder auf diese Entscheidung
nun immer stärker durch die
polit-taktische Brille schaut und was er
da sieht das ist ein echtes Dilemma und
die Wahl zwischen zwei Alternativen die
beide große Risiken bergen sollte er
Hubert awanger am Ende nicht entlassen
dann würde er Gefahr laufen auch Zweifel
an seine an seinem eigenen
aufklärungswillen zu streuen denn Markus
Söder hat die Latte ja sehr sehr hoch
gehängt hat von ekligen widerlichen
Vorwürfen gesprochen die jetzt
zweifelsfrei aufgeklärt werden müssen
und wenn Zweifel an Hubert Aiwanger
bleiben am Ende dann würden immer auch
Zweifel an Markus Söder haften bleiben
Möglichkeit zwei er entlässt Hubert
Aiwanger auch das ist mit großen Risiken
behaftet denn dann lief die CSU Gefahr
ihren Koalitionspartner zu verlieren
müsste einen Wahlkampf plötzlich
konstruieren ohne die die Macht Option
mit den freien Wäldern weiter zu
regieren der ganze csu-wahlkampf war
eigentlich darauf ausgerichtet auf die
Fortsetzung der sogenannten Bayern
Koalition und er müsste einen komplett
neuen Wahlkampf entwerfen wann Markus
Söder entscheidet wissen wir nicht er
arbeitet im Moment genauso wie Hubert
awanger auch sehr diszipliniert die
politischen Termine ab ein Termin steht
fest der findet morgen statt das ist das
ZDF sommerinterview und egal wie Markus
Söder entscheidet wann er entscheidet
der Termin steht morgen das ZDF Sommer
Interview danke schön für diese
Einschätzung aus München
ein klares Nein kommt vom Bundeskanzler
zur weiteren Nutzung von Atomkraft das
Thema Kernkraft ist ein totes Pferd
sagte Scholz dem Deutschlandfunk der
Ausstieg sei gesetzlich erfolgt mit dem
Ende der Nutzung habe der Abbau begonnen
gestern hatte die
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion gefordert auf den
Rückbau der drei noch einsatzfähigen
Atomkraftwerke vorerst zu verzichten
CDU-Chef Friedrich Merz hat sich offen
für Vorschläge auch aus seiner eigenen
Partei gezeigt den Spitzensteuersatz zu
erhöhen es sei nicht entscheidend ob der
Satz künftig bei 42 oder 45 Prozent
liege wichtig sei eine Entlastung der
Mittelschicht so märz in der Frankfurter
Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung die
Belastungskurve gehören abgeflacht den
Leistung müsse sich lohnen
eines der großen streithemen der
Ampelkoalition war die Kinder
Grundsicherung
2025 soll sie kommen und mehr
Chancengerechtigkeit bringen die grüne
Familienministerin paulus hatte mehr
Geld gefordert nach ihrer Aussage können
Familien armutsgefährdeter Kinder
künftig mit bis zu 636 Euro monatlich
rechnen abhängig vom Alter des Kindes
gerade jetzt zum Schulstart müssen
Eltern viel bezahlen Susanne Freitag
kataron berichtet
serias Schultüte ist fertig gebastelt
und befüllt mit Hilfe der
Arbeiterwohlfahrt eine Aktion für
wirtschaftlich schwache Familien in
Saarbrücken serias Mutter ist
alleinerziehend hat zwei Kinder im
schulpflichtigen Alter die
schultütenaktion eine große Hilfe
schäme mich wenn ich auf meinen Kindern
nicht gut mit allem versorgen kann ja
und muss immer Aktionen schauen es ist
einfach nicht leicht zu im Moment ein
paar Kilometer weiter verteilt der
Kinderschutzbund gespendete Schultaschen
die Nachfrage nach solchen Angeboten
explodiert wie die Kinderarmut die wird
immer sichtbarer sagen die Mitarbeiter
der Sozialverbände 2,4 Milliarden Euro
sollen in die Kinder Grundsicherung
investiert werden das jetzt dieser
Betrag dabei herausgekommen ist also ich
denke da sind wir Sozialverbände uns
alle einig das ist nichtmals ein Tropfen
auf den heißen Stein es ist ein Anfang
aber der Anfang ist viel zu gering
in dieser Schule in Berlin Spandau ging
es heute los mit einer Feierstunde hier
im Brennpunkt ist die Kinderarmut noch
höher als im Bundesdurchschnitt wir
fordern sie auch mehr Investitionen in
Sprachförderung Kitas und Schulen
wünschen wir natürlich für meine Kinder
hier in diesem brennpunktgebiet dass sie
wirklich eine Chancengleichheit bekommen
wenn Kinder keine Teilhabe bekommen oder
einfach irgendwo abgehängt werden die
sind danach nachher Nachteile oder
bekommen keine Ausbildungsplätze dann
sind die die nächsten Sozialfälle
Wirtschaftsforscher schätzen dass die
Kinderarmut den Staat jährlich 110 bis
120 Milliarden Euro kostet ein
Vielfaches dessen was jetzt in die
Kindergrundsicherung investiert wird
schauen wir uns Ausland in Tel Aviv sind
nach schweren Zusammenstößen zwischen
Migranten aus Eritrea und der
israelischen Polizei mindestens 150
Menschen verletzt worden 19 sogar schwer
die Beamten mussten nach eigenen Angaben
wegen der unmittelbaren gefahrschüsse
abgeben unter den Verletzten sind auch
49 Polizisten hunderte Eritrea hatten
vor der Botschaft ihres Landes gegen die
dortige diktaturprotestiert auch in
Deutschland war es im Juli bei einem
Eritrea Festival zur Ausschreitungen
gekommen
auch in Zypern gab es krawalle am Abend
kam es nach einer Demonstration gegen
Flüchtlinge und Migranten zu schweren
Ausschreitungen hunderte zum Teil
vermummte zogen durch die Hafenstadt
Limassol sie griffen Migranten an und
zerstörten deren Geschäfte es gab 13
Festnahmen mindestens fünf Menschen
wurden verletzt
nach mehr als 10 Jahren Bürgerkrieg
Flammen in Syrien die Proteste wieder
auf und zwar nicht nur in den
rebellengebieten demonstriert wird gegen
schlechte Lebensbedingungen steigende
Preise und gegen die Regierung Assad
bereits seit mehr als zwei Wochen gehen
Menschen vor allem in zu weider im Süden
des Landes auf die Straße die Region ist
das Kernland der drusenminderheit von
der Gewalt der Assad-Regierung wurde sie
bisher weitgehend verschont anders heißt
berichtet
dass diese Bilder uns erreichen ist
nicht selbstverständlich sie bezeugen
die größten Proteste in von Assad
kontrollierten Gebieten seit Jahren seit
15 Tagen protestieren die Einwohner der
Stadt zu jeder bisher greifen die
Sicherheitskräfte nicht ein doch gestern
Nachmittag wurde das Internet
weitestgehend eingestellt das bedeutet
nichts Gutes Arm die Einheimischen
doch der Reihe nach suader der 18 August
sie rufen barschar hau ab die Menschen
hier sind sauer denn wenige Tage zuvor
wurden die Subventionen für Benzin
aufgehoben die Währung komplett wertlos
schon jetzt leben neun von zehn Syrern
in Armut
die Menschen können nicht mehr sie
können nicht mehr atmen sie sehen wie
die Preise steigen ohne Ende
Machthaber Assad lässt die täglichen
Proteste bisher gewähren obwohl Bilder
von ihm verbrannt werden eine seiner
Parteizentralen angegriffen wurde in den
sozialen Medien melden sich nun seine
Unterstützer mit einer klaren Drohung
ich warne euch bald wird es einen Besuch
geben ich sage euch nicht wer aber da
wird wer sehr bald zu euch nach sueda
kommen
doch davon lassen Sie sich nicht
einschüchtern diese
Politikwissenschaftlerin ist eigens aus
Damaskus angereist wie viele hier
ich rufe alle Syrer aus allen Städten
auf uns zu folgen das könnte unser
historischer Moment werden
entweder jetzt oder nie
obwohl der Druck auf die Gemeinde
zunehme das Internet heute weiter von
der Regierung blockiert werde die
Demonstranten wollen weitermachen
[Applaus]
zum Krieg in der Ukraine Moskau hat
vergangenen Nacht nach eigenen Angaben
drei ukrainische See Drohnenangriffe auf
die krimbrücke abgewehrt die Brücke ist
für Russland strategisch wichtig etwa
für die Versorgung der Truppen auf der
völkerrechtlich annektierten Halbinsel
bei der ukrainischen Gegenoffensive hier
nahebach Mut im Osten des Landes sieht
Kiew Fortschritte die ukrainischen
Truppen rückten voran so Präsident
silensky
im russischen Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine bietet sich immer wieder Papst
franziskus als Vermittler an bei seinem
Besuch in der Mongolei rief er dazu auf
die dunklen Wolken des Krieges zu
vertreiben ein deutlicher Wink an die
Nachbarländer Russland und China die
Mongolei ist eine Demokratie sie ist
viermal so groß wie Deutschland hat aber
nur 3,4 Millionen Einwohner die meisten
davon Buddhisten katholisch sind nur
etwa 1400 mehr von Andreas poste
an die Ränder gehen dahin wo kein Papst
vor ihm war das gefällt Franziskus und
selbst dann wenn es dem Hochbetagten
Pontifex schwer fällt bei den wenigen
den Armen den allein gelassenen da solle
seine Kirche sein nur knapp 1.400
katholische Gläubige gibt es in der
Mongolei fast alle sind wohl gekommen
den Papst seit seiner Ankunft und wir
sind sehr glücklich über seinem Besuch
Staatsempfang in der Hauptstadt Ulan
Bator dessen Präsidentin Besuch des
Papstes als Aufwertung seines Landes
verstehen kann Papst franziskus würdig
den nachhaltigen Umgang mit der Natur
die Abschaffung der Todesstrafe in der
Mongolei und den Einsatz gegen
Atomwaffen
eine demokratische Nation die eine
friedliche Außenpolitik betreibt sondern
sie ist bestrebt eine wichtige Rolle für
den Weltfrieden zu spielen
ein diplomatischer Draht Verlag der den
Papst diesmal zu gelingen scheint das
Lob für die Mongolei kann als Signal an
die beiden direkten benachbarten
Großmächte Russland und China verstanden
werden eine Reise dorthin blieb den
Papst bislang verwehrt
dafür sind kleine Gruppen chinesischer
Katholiken nach Ulan Bator gereist eine
offenbares Kante Reise sie wollen nicht
erkannt werden in der Kathedrale der
Hauptstadt Lob Papst franziskus die
Religionsfreiheit in der Mongolei so die
Botschaft ist die katholische Kirche
willkommen und was hier möglich sei
könne doch auch bei den großen Nachbarn
möglich sein deutlicher als mit dieser
mongolei-reise kann der Papst seinen
Friedenswillen momentan kaum
signalisieren
irgendwie ehrbacher begleitet die
Papstreise Jürgen es gibt in der
Mongolei nur sehr wenige Katholiken
warum besucht franziskus dieses Land
der Papst hat strategische Ziele er ist
bereits zum fünften Mal in Fernost die
katholische Kirche wächst in Asien da
will er präsent sein und die lokalen
Kirchen unterstützen und dann ist das
große Ziel China der Nachbar hier der
Mongolei es gibt keine diplomatischen
Beziehungen zwischen dem Vatikan und
Peking man befürchtet dort zu starke
Einmischung in innerer Angelegenheiten
und so umkreist der Papst mit seinen
Reisen China und gibt immer wieder
deutliche Botschaften heute Abend zum
Beispiel hat er gesagt keine Regierung
muss die katholische Kirche fürchten
denn sie hat keine politische Agenda
sondern will das Wohl aller Menschen
einem Land fördern auf dem Weg hierher
von Rom nach unabharte und Papst
franziskus dem chinesischen Präsidenten
ein Großteil der Gramm aus dem Flieger
geschickt aus Peking kam die Redaktion
wir wollen daran arbeiten die
Beziehungen zu verbessern verbessern
will franziskus hier auch das Verhältnis
zu den asiatischen Religionen er sucht
Partner im Einsatz gegen religiösen
Fanatismus für den 86-jährigen ist das
die vier te Auslandsreise in diesem Jahr
die fünfte folgt in wenigen Wochen man
merkt dem Papst die Strapazen an doch
trotzdem Mühe man kann ihn nicht bremsen
danke schön nach Ulan Bator danke Jürgen
Erbacher
zurück nach Deutschland
Anfeindungen Diskriminierung Gewalt das
Erleben Schwule Lesben transmessen
überhaupt queere Menschen immer wieder
ein Blick auf die Statistik zeigt 2007
registrierte die Polizei noch 63
queerfeindliche Delikte etwa
Beleidigungen im vergangenen Jahr waren
es mehr als 1000 auch die Zahl der
erfassten Gewalttaten steigt zuletzt
waren es 227 auch wenn die Bereitschaft
zugenommen hat Übergriffe anzuzeigen die
Dunkelziffer dürfte hoch sein in
Frankfurt am Main hat man reagiert
Susanna
es war im letzten Jahr als Manuel ilbeck
brutal angegriffen wurde nur weil er
schwul ist der 27-Jährige war mit einem
kumpelarmen Arm unterwegs als ein Mann
seinen Freund in die Seite schlug und
sie hat [__] beschimpfte und
daraufhin hat der Angreifer seine Faust
gezogen mit irgendeinem harten
Metallgegenstand wohl und hat mich voll
am Kinn getroffen und zwar so heftig
dass mir nicht nur der Kiefer gebrochen
ist sondern ich wirklich direkt k.o war
die Polizei konnte den Mann fassen dem
das angetan hat sechs Wochen lang hatte
Manuel Stellschrauben in seinem
Kieferknochen konnte den Mund nicht
öffnen meistens geht die Gewalt gegen
Quere von jungen Männern in einer Gruppe
aus sagt die Frankfurter Polizei
Herkunft oder Religion spielten keine
Rolle es sind keine bestimmten
Tätergruppen die die Straftaten gegen
die queren Menschen gehen es sind halt
oder größtenteils Zufallsbegegnungen auf
die zunehmende Gewalt hat die Polizei
mit einer erhöhten Präsenz im
sogenannten regenbogenviertel reagiert
hier befinden sich viele quiere Bars
außerdem gibt es künftig mehr Kühe
beauftragte im letzten Jahr wurden immer
mehr Angriffe registriert da sagen wir
aber auch das hat damit zu tun dass wir
das Dunkelfeld erhellen weil wir
ermutigen durch sehen Rundgänge und
Gespräche mit der Tieren Community das
überhaupt erst Straftaten angezeigt
werden auch die Night Queens haben
mehrfach Gewalt erlebt so nennen sich
diese schwulen Männer wenn sie wie hier
in Wiesbaden öffentlich auftreten in
ihrer Frauenrolle sehen Sie eine
Kunstfigur
ja wenn du Sprüche kommen haben wir
Glück gehabt an Silvester bei einem
booking wurden Raketen auf mich
gerichtet und losgeschossen so viele
Mädels die schon Prellungen Rippenbrüche
eine Flasche durchs Gesicht gezogen
gekriegt haben und das alles nur weil
sie eine Kunst ausleben
die Night Queens trauen sich abends
alleine nicht auf die Straße Manuel Beck
leidet bis heute unter dem Angriff der
Täter muss sich unter anderem wegen
schwerer Körperverletzung verantworten
seit der Landung der Mondsonde vor zehn
Tagen gehört Indien zum erlauchten Kreis
der mondfahrnationen jetzt greift das
Land zu den Sternen und zwar zu dem für
uns wichtigsten unsere Sonne an Bord
einer Träger Rakete wurde ein
Forschungssatellit ins All geschossen in
vier Monaten wird er seinen Platz an der
Sonne erreicht haben und aus 1,5
Millionen Kilometer Entfernung sondern
wenn der erkunden
jetzt Fußball nun hat Eintracht
Frankfurt seinen Topstürmer doch noch
verkauft praktisch ein Last Minute Deal
ja das Transferfenster zur Bundesliga
war ja schon geschlossen aber das
Fenster nach Frankreich das stand noch
offen und so hat er vorübergehend
streikende französische Nationalspieler
doch noch seinen Willen bekommen und
spielt jetzt für Paris Saint-Germain
es war ein Spiel gegen die Zeit 0.30
heute morgen meldeten beide Parteien
Vollzug Transfer in letzter Sekunde
Randal Kolonie bis gestern noch
Eintrachtler heute schon großer
Hoffnungsträger beim französischen
Meister
hallo ich bin's Randal ich bin stolz und
glücklich hier zu sein im Park
in Hessen werden sie ihn vermissen 50
Pflichtspiele 26 Tore 95 Millionen war
dieses Paket
rekordablöse für ein Spieler der Hessen
alles gut für Spieler Frankfurt und
Paris
bei der Eintracht beklagen sie eine
sportliche Lücke in Gang kam aus Berlin
und Oma mamusch Torschütze gegen Mainz
müssen diese schließen wo eine Tür
zugeht öffnet sich eine andere für mich
heißt die nächste Station Paris
Bayer Leverkusen untermauert seine
Ambitionen auf eine Top-Platzierung in
der Fußball-Bundesliga drittes
Saisonspiel 3 Sieg gegen Aufsteiger
Darmstadt gewinnt die Werkself mit fünf
zu eins noch deutlicher der
überraschungsieg des VfB Stuttgart gegen
Freiburg 5 zu 0 die ersten Punkte für
Bremen vier zu null gegen Mainz 05 der
erste Punkt Verlust für Wolfsburg 1 zu 3
in Hoffenheim und Augsburg gegen Bochum
2:2 aktuell läuft der Klassiker Gladbach
gegen Bayern München gestern der erste
Bundesliga Punkt der Vereinsgeschichte
für Heidenheim 22 in Dortmund 2 Spiele
morgen
Leverkusen zumindest vorläufig
Tabellenführer vor Stuttgart Union und
die Bayern können noch Punkten dortmund
kann theoretisch noch auf Platz 11
zurückfallen die Mannschaften am Platz
12 noch sieglos ganz ohne Punkte bisher
Köln und Schlusslicht Darmstadt
die Bundesliga komplett natürlich
ausführlich mit Gladbach gegen Bayern um
23 Uhr im Aktuellen Sportstudio zu Gast
ist der deutsche zehnkampfrekordler Leo
neu gebaut
die deutschen Volleyballer stehen bei
der Europameisterschaft noch mit weißer
Weste da zweites Gruppenspiel zweiter
Sieg 13:0 gegen die Auswahl der Schweiz
in Perugia
gegen den Underdog aus der Schweiz
spielt das deutsche Männerteam mit
veränderter Aufstellung die Stammspieler
Georg grosser und Lukas Camper werden
geschont doch Zuspieler Johannes Zille
setzt die jungen Angreifer exzellente
Szene nach nur 21 Minuten ist der erste
Satz perfekt auch den zweiten Durchgang
gewinnt die DVV-Auswahl mit deutlichem
Abstand im dritten Satz liegen die
Schweizer zunächst in Führung doch mit
starken Angriffen und einer guten
geschlossenen Mannschaftsleistung holt
sich das deutsche Team letztlich den
Satz und gewinnt so auch das zweite
Spiel souverän mit 3:0 morgen wartet
dann auf Bundestrainer Michael und seine
Auswahl mit Belgien ein stärkere Gegner
und dann sind auch die Basketballer
wieder dran die können bei der WM ihre
Siegesserie ausbauen gegen Slowenien
genau danke schön und Basketball bewegt
nicht nur Menschen das beweist diese
Orte Dame in einem Zoo im US-Bundesstaat
Oregon zielsicher schnappt sich Juno den
Ball und stopft ihn in den Kopf das
nennt man im Basketball
geradezu meisterhaft für sie ist es
allerdings eine Art Reha-Maßnahme die
Danks sollen gegen die Arthrose in ihrem
Ellenbogen helfen
warmes und sonniges Spätsommerwetter vom
Feinsten prognostiziert gleich Katja
horneffer Viertel vor elf begrüßt Sie
Christian Sievers im heute-journal wir
sagen danke und tschüss und bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen
[Musik]
guten Abend jetzt kommt der Spätsommer
das hängt zusammen mit diesem hohen
Luftdruck übermittelt Europa flankiert
bitte hohe Luftdruck durch gleich zwei
Tiefs und das Tief über die iberischen
Halbinsel bringt tatsächlich noch mal
spät Sommer Wärme zu uns nach
Deutschland heute Nacht ist es zum Teil
erstmal klar hier im Südwesten
Deutschlands im Nordosten ist es dagegen
stärker bewölkt und dazwischen bildet
sich Nebel die Temperaturen sinken auf
15 bis 10 Grad und liegen morgen ganz im
Norden um 20 Grad 29 Grad werden es am
Oberrhein das wird ein sehr freundlicher
Sonntag und besonders im Westen scheint
die Sonne zum Teil strahlend einzig in
Ostbayern sind einige kleine
Regenschauer nicht ganz ausgeschlossen
spätsommerlich warm geht's dann in den
nächsten Tagen weiter und sehr sonnig
war Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 22 und
31 Grad und wenn Sie sich fragen wie es
nach der Woche Mitte weiter geht naja es
bleibt warm wie sich am Trend für
Mannheim gut sehen können da gibt es
mehrere Tage am Stück um die 30 Grad
auch in Norddeutschland kommt die Wärme
an es wird nicht ganz so warm wie sie
hier in Flensburg sehen können aber
immerhin 25 Grad sind es dann doch meist
guten Abend